you can choose to feed your family
whatever way you need to I have zero
judgment on it what I do acknowledge is
that people make associations and so I
could find the most ethical porn
business in the entire world as soon as
I stand on stage and talk about our porn
company I will forever be associated
with porn is there anything wrong with
that yes or no I don't know for me I
think that there are other businesses I
would like to do a deal with that might
view that negatively and so it might
prevent me from doing a much bigger deal
in the future by having that and so I
won't do it not out of principle but out
of pure dollar and cense materialism if
you want to call it that